it started off with a conversation
within the associates network and then
we were thinking about how
usually design exhibitions are
prescriptive and top down
as if it's telling you a particular
point of view and that this is what it
is you wanted to think about oh how we
can how do we know what's designed how
do we know actually if there's value in
design
so
we were a bit tricky and wanted to you
know use the design center
to really question the value of design
so people come in they're supposed to be
in this
you know suspended state
and while they look all through the
exhibition they're able to
really be critical and make a decision
for themselves about
whether design is valuable
[Music]
you